[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
welcome to our show see Moo oh it's so
good to be here thank you for having me
I keep forgetting your real life and
your show life Kim's convenience I'll be
like you when you're gonna get what the
girl your manager man yeah and I'm like
oh wait that's not your real you
yeah it's emojis it's Chinese yeah how
do you produce it in lucema okay then oh
your last name first in there first yeah
yeah record so we just finished filming
our third season we know we're coming
back for a fourth but yeah we're just
that thank you you guys haven't seen it
Kim's convenience on a Netflix it is
awesome it is my childhood in a show
like when I first saw it so I came
across all you [ __ ] American [ __ ]
[ __ ] that told me that would it make
sense as a TV show [ __ ] you yeah it's
like so implausible to them like oh
that's not real yeah like what no it's
just a lot of this like a lot of like
small Korean businesses have those same
parallels right yeah like for example
like how we treat customers how we see
customers all that other stuff is such a
parallel to my life growing up and all
stories I told here on JK knew yeah and
but then when you because you're copying
them from Kim's convenience right
even though dick easy they're real for
like 10 years I was like damn this is a
funny show I pitched this before though
yeah you know and it just didn't seem
real wrong place wrong time in the wrong
country dude [ __ ] I should do the wrong
country
yeah well so Kim's communion started as
a play right so though the playwright in
Choi workshop this place since like like
from like 2007 he was like writing this
play and then it somehow made its way
into the Toronto Fringe Festival which
is like a theater festival awesome ended
up getting picked up by one of the major
theatre companies and then through there
ended up getting optioned into a TV show
because like you could see like when you
watch the play on stage you're like it
felt like you were watching
like a live audience watching a sitcom
and so it was like a way for the I feel
like the TV executives to like actually
see it in practice and so you know you
could very clearly see the sitcom setup
you could see it in them kids could be
it's an actual place to write is it an
actual place yeah it wasn't it wasn't
before the show started shooting but we
we found this we found this convenience
store called Mimi's variety and
basically offered them you know a little
bit of a stipend and we put up because
we need an exterior shot of the of the
convenience store so we put up the signs
and everything and it was so funny like
they you know I think they may have been
a little reluctant at first but then the
show came out and it did really well and
they're like we ain't ever taken this
off yeah it was it was such a heart I
feel like it when I was having these
meetings it was such a hard press
because it was very difficult for them
to understand an Asian urban character
yeah so that's the thing that's the
thing that that's that's the parallel it
doesn't match it's like for me it was me
as a kid growing up where I couldn't
identify one of the who the [ __ ] I was
it was like are you like you're a you're
a Korean American immigrant but you grew
up in a predominantly black neighborhood
so you were late to both sides so you
just don't know where you belong mm-hmm
you know and I think that was like a
little weird for them they didn't get
maybe even even some Asians are like
that because when me and Bart did a show
at Stanford University one kid during
the Q&A was asking hey uh why does David
act black you know it's our show yeah
and I was like wait what are you talking
about like you know like you know the
way he talks and stuff and I'm like you
do know that there's a lot of Asians
that grow up around Hispanics or like
black just like there are like Asian
kids that only grew up in white
neighborhoods you know and were you like
he doesn't you know how do you act up a
lot and yeah you adopt you learn you
know the mannerisms the English and all
that through your environment yeah and
then they're like oh what like no
[ __ ] clue I mean it's a odd concept
like I didn't know like even to be a
hundred percent if you if people hear me
speak right now unless I go back to my
old neighborhood Sacramento right if
they hear me speak to me I don't sound
orbán at all
I sound straight white American but to
people who are extremely white American
I sound urban to them so
I'm in this weird blend right cuz I
still speak Korean fluently I you know I
grew up college-educated whatever so I
had this weird blend in this room
it comes out whenever it wants you know
so like certain words that I saved
myself that the certain words don't yeah
I was always stuck in the middle so I
had this like weird identity crisis yeah
man this I think this concept of stuck
in the middle like especially in our
generation is gonna be such a big thing
because I honestly honestly believe that
the next generation of like Asian kids
growing up in America Canada or whatever
have you will have like a wealth of like
Asian diasporic material to kind of draw
from when they asked the inevitable
question of like Who am I and what is
this place that I'm growing up in even
you know my parents are speaking a
different language but the people that I
go to school would speak another
language like I just feel like in our
generation we had no answer to that
because we had no identity of our own
yeah in terms of like Asian Asian or
American America there was no Asian
American there was no marriage of those
two things yeah it's it's something that
like I don't know I guess I'm really
excited cause I feel like you guys are a
part of it I feel like people like Wong
foo are a part of it yeah it's just this
if we're building for the first time
this like collective identity where it
doesn't matter so much where your
parents came from Korea China Japan you
know whatever wherever have you but it's
like it's it's like we're all here now
so we might as well that's that was our
philosophy for the longest time and we
created JK between me and Bart we made
it an effort to not tell or talk about
our ethnicities mm-hmm because what you
know like ten years ago
Asians didn't have that identity things
so they would claim us I we saw that
early on they'll be like oh he's one of
us he's Korean yeah he you know [ __ ]
this guy or that guy cuz they're not one
of us so it's there's a lot of
infighting you know we're like we're
like that doesn't make no sense man like
all of our friends are just different
ethnicity nation beyond Asians to relive
a different experience so we shouldn't
make it so much about the identity in a
group we should just make it about our
experiences and no one figured it out
for the longest time but we made a
conscious effort to not say it because
of that reason we wanted people to just
identify through our skill and efforts
in the stories and I think and I think
we are more similar than we're different
I mean
from the languages that our parents
spoke it's like we all know what it
feels you know parental pressure
intergenerational conscience in the face
[Laughter]
things I'll resonate with me
yeah our food is a little different yeah
we speak slightly different languages
but bamboo stick dude every source P
analysts tell yeah most sort no family
discussions yeah homosexuality don't
exist no expression of love or emotion
ever bow son Korea churches all the time
for no reason even when you Chinese or
Vietnamese oh yeah music though yeah how
did you become a part of the project did
you like audition or were you like yeah
yeah so I I mean I wasn't a part of the
play or anything like Paul and gene who
play I'm mine up by the parents they
were they've kind of been with the
project since day one you know they were
part of like the inception of the
characters in a lot of ways the
characters themselves were basic actors
seemed so natural
oh yeah yeah he's been I mean he's been
playing that role for like a long time a
really really long time but I came I
came on board when when it was already
like very far into its own process they
were already they were casting for the
show and I just kind of I auditioned
didn't know if I was gonna be able to do
it cuz I wasn't on another show at the
time called taken with Liam Neeson yeah
so they made it into a show NBC did it
lasted two seasons you were on the beat
you I take it with Liam Neeson I would
know you know when they reboot these
shows for TV they never keep the the
franchise actors right no but still
though it was it for Stargate good day I
think taking the TV show the one that
originated with Liam Neeson
I was in I was in every episode of the
first season and the kidnapping some
people know we were we were like a part
of this like CIA splinter team hi and so
I literally I did this for 10 episodes I
was like the computer nerd I can say
this now that the show is cancelled but
we're some of the lines which have to
say ok so it's like I I came on board
like I thought like a very strong stunt
guy like I had a really strong stunt
background gymnastics martial arts
whatever so my thinking getting cast on
a show like taken was like I want to get
to do something yeah beat some people up
where they like here the classes in the
computer ya know they're like boom
you're gonna be here and like I would
just be watching some of the some of the
actors with the stunts and I was like I
felt like I could do it oh yeah you
could do it why don't you type and then
just [ __ ] random II thought
what do you mean over oh yeah I would
have loved to do some stunts on this
show but after the first season they
ended up doing this big hole
reorganizing thing where they brought on
a new showrunner and a whole new support
cast so all of us through like Call
Sheet number 3 to 11 we're let go they
brought in a new cast for season 2 and
then the and then the show and I being
cancelled so that's because they didn't
let you do your stunts only are you
gonna trying to nudge them for season or
you already shot season four not yet not
yet no you tell them like hey can we get
do some fight scenes you guys get into
trouble with some Toronto gang okay you
got a protective force because Jun's
past comes back to haunt
you should have a weird slightly tall
Korean chubby guy that has a slight
urban flip slightly your cousin from
America Nima D mu so two friends named G
mu and B mu yeah yeah I don't know
anything I don't know anybody who would
put those two characters but I don't
know anyone know that that's a practice
you were you are freaking amazing in GU
what pic like amazing thank you so much
that's like my pride and joy you you pop
you know what I mean I noticed that and
Bachelorette to like you just like you
just pop like it is so watchable no
that's true that's true you can't be
that nice to him okay I was like one of
those like film film things where it's
like I feel like if I had my film career
that I'd be happy just because like I
think I got spoiled with being able to
do my own project and then when I tried
doing acting which I still AM I'd
realize that it's a different world when
you are auditioning versus you creating
yeah you're not in control I'm not in
control and that's the part that was
killing me the most because I would get
these grips and I'm like these a
distraction you know cuz I was on the
other end and when I got to create the
story and yeah jokes and everything and
then I'm looking at it I'm like I like
it I mean but that's not your position
as an app yeah you're supposed to take
that work and then try to embody what
they're doing to the best of your you
know and I didn't know how to do that
cuz I was doing the other way you're but
you're better composer then you are a
player totally yeah and you know what
let's just like you know sometimes
depending on what set you go on to
there's this like air of superiority
with the writers 100% you know they
don't like how dare you challenge me
you're just an actor so just do a job
you know go to work say the lines that
you're told to say but that's out there
right like a lot of times we don't get
we don't get the kind of respect what I
found out too was that I like I like to
film a lot cuz I like the finite story
that you tell you put this out there
this is the story wrapped up in one
package you take it you do it and then
you move on to their next project I
think what TV it was so hard because
you're looking at longevity at this
point right so you're gonna take this
carrots gonna Paul over X amount of
years and then that started freaking me
out a little bit
do I like that or do I like film right
[Laughter]
they said they brought it back like a
second version of it they call it
something else a total oh right it is
called something else I don't know if it
ever reached Canada so I don't know if I
don't know buying no no vide reach
Canada but whatever the new vine is no I
don't know yeah man you want you want
you want some other level maybe which is
tight you need both no though these days
huh like you needed social presents yeah
following it's like yeah yeah everyone's
doing everything I think that's the new
model I don't think I mean for people
who are like innately very proactive and
and very wired to like work I think
being an actor is the worst sometimes
because you so like you spent so little
of your job actually working most of its
auditioning right yeah it's auditioning
and they're just like waiting yeah so
like with acting there should be classes
on how to stay positive
cuz that's the hard part totally just
like managing your own mental health
while you're going this time that you're
not getting booked you still have to
work on a craft that you're not sure
that you're gonna get picked for you
know so you go into these it's like if
how I explain to people it's like how
would you like to go into a job
interview [ __ ] ten times a [ __ ]
week and have people tell you no every
[ __ ] time
no you're not gonna know you're not
gonna know you're not good enough I'll
call you back and you know what they
mean that's what they [ __ ] me yeah
and no you're not gonna know oh I would
rather I would rather to just say no
exactly cuz they say with nothing yeah
look oh thank you for your time no the
nice sucker was that good you were bad
I'll work on it I'll come back yeah
exactly exactly cuz you don't want to be
at home I wish they picked me right yeah
alright cuz when you do you know when
you're when you're like trying to
present something to a client they'll be
like thank you this is our
be back right and that's how you like
improve but when you don't ever get the
feedback or when you get feedback like
it is nothing to do with you you know
it's sometimes it's just it's totally
out of your control like well what the
hell am I supposed to do with that the
worst thing that I got that I told that
I specifically asked people not to tell
me now it's like specially with agency
goes if I didn't get something don't
tell me don't tell me that I could have
got it but something happened just say I
didn't get it and I'll move on because
it's useless for you to tell me that
doesn't give me hope mm-hmm it's not
like there was a project that I almost
booked it did it got shelled anyway so
it didn't matter but the reason why I
didn't get is because I didn't have any
formal TV experience mm-hm and so Marvel
didn't want to take a chance on me so
it's like why'd you tell me that no
majority of actors out there can't
handle the truth mm-hmm and everyone
responds to it differently I think
because our agent has to fluff and talk
and we're like 90% of the conversation
and then he gives us the news or he
talks about what he really wants to talk
about and that pisses me off because I'm
like you talk too much
two hours of my [ __ ] time telling me
how great I am don't do that mm-hmm just
tell me in five minutes or write me a
sentence in an email and we'll move on
but they're not used to that they have
to like break the news in a certain way
because other people would just be
devastated they probably don't want to
work with them anymore
so but they're so used to I think
speaking like Liars you know like just
constantly fluffing [ __ ] up or whatever
yeah yeah and I'm it drives me crazy
because I'm like I'm with you I'd rather
just be told no or I rather be just told
straight up thank you if they say I got
the information I could move on if you
like did an audition and you go honestly
your lives were a little awkward and it
felt like you're really uncomfortable
with this character that's not cool I
could build on that yeah yeah gave me
something yeah yeah thank you now I
could go out and I could work on this
and maybe when I do another audition I
won't make that same mistake but then
that's also not fair because I've done
casting where I'm on the end that I
already know what the role that I'm
trying to get and the vibe and the the
book like all of that where I'm just
like I don't need to tell you that like
you need to work on that because it's
like this is just this role is not you
and you're not what I'm looking for for
this particular roles
I got that that's pretty cool that's a
lot of times you don't know if it's
right or wrong or if it's a creative
direction difference or like if they
don't give you a chance to even give
another take at it and force out to be
this gay guy on his HBO series and when
I want a wife I did my research I
watched a series a lot and I practiced
my buddy Lawrence the lines going over
it what he thought what the series of
feel is supposed to be and and so I did
a very light comedic take on it because
the series was so dramatic and then
later on I found out that they just they
were looking for comedians on purpose
because they wanted someone to play it
really loud but they wouldn't they
didn't tell me that or didn't even tell
me hey do you do you have any other
perspectives on how you can do this and
you just don't know these things so a
lot like you aren't flaming enough yeah
you just do it and they just call thank
you and then I'm like okay I don't know
if I killed it or not or and I could've
gave it to you on the other side too to
be a hundred percent honest even Kastner
doesn't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
too because they all they'll try to pick
their pull of people that they think are
dope they'll send it to the whatever
producer and be like nah this is it yeah
they go back to the drawing what a
broken system
it's such a weird system this is my one
thing about the industry that and I
don't want to I don't want to like
poopoo anybody or what they do I can't I
respect everyone if you want but it's
like but it's like any industry that's
built on so many middle people very
frustrating for the people well it makes
sense because it's a system like well so
film in Hollywood it's a hundred plus
years now mm-hmm the industry has been
around for a long time and the way that
they do things it made sense for a
specific reason like casting for TV or
casting for film and it worked because
they needed to fix something because
there was a problem but then when that
problem disappears that system is still
in place and people want to keep their
jobs or they don't even know why it's
there anymore so I think like now with
independent filmmakers that are cutting
through a lot of this [ __ ] nonsense
we can make decisions weight quicker
because there's no red tape but then
these bigger companies to Plus they run
with billions of dollars opposed to our
like small little budgets or
they have a lot on the line there's jobs
on the line
there's people's reputation on the line
there's so much on the line that no one
wants to take responsibility or take a
chance or make a mistake for sure
Hardman like-like-like I understand on
the other end too because they just
sometimes they just don't know what they
want that's why you'll see these casting
was like well let's get a Hispanic black
Mexican or white person what you want
the person can be funny tall fat or
skinny oh my god so you go into this
wallet [ __ ] get my like I've done so
many roles but I like audition for Jose
Hernandez you know ha I'm not Mexican I
don't know what's going on here but then
I did well because they didn't know what
they wanted and I showed this something
that they could probably want then I get
a call back in another callback yeah
yeah you made strong choices you came
out with a very clear idea and then yeah
it turns out that afterwards they
[ __ ] hired Davonte Williams okay like
I've literally got into a role once
where they said specifically they want
they don't want a urban funny black
person they want somebody to be in the
urban yet but not black right they hit
me up cool when in I got a callback the
person that he hired was a black dude
they don't know what they want cuz I saw
it I saw it like on the I was like oh
[ __ ] that's the role I audition for the
black but you said you don't want a
black guy yeah does it they don't know
yeah that means that they don't know
that they're just gonna wait to see
something that they like so you just
have to go on the shoot at the dark I
don't know if this happens frequently on
film but when we did our rounds pitching
TV shows it blew my mind how fast people
switch jobs in Hollywood yeah so damn
fast like even in high executive
positions do that just it's like one day
we're meeting with the executive of this
and then like oh he's now gone to this
studio and yeah it's like what the [ __ ]
and then they keep changing their
company direction like every few months
and it's like yeah well we were looking
to do budget short films and then TV
shows but now we're going to
documentaries or it's like what the [ __ ]
there's like a couple months ago there's
like so many executives that I've met
and then I meet them again like oh by
the way I'm looking for Amazon now all
right cool then then I think again like
while I'm over back at NBC
what the [ __ ] going on - where are you
at and this is because even their jobs
are so fleeting yeah yeah yeah I can see
how things are so fickle and like it
changed us like so fast and crazy it I
think it's really ramped up recently too
I mean the the landscape now is like I
feel like if I were in that traditional
model I would be a little bit panicked -
it's hard this because like if you're
for example if you're like a TV network
you know traditional like national TV
network like you've got like competition
coming out in places that you don't even
know that competition could exist now
there's like there's like 20,000
streaming platforms and like everything
you're just competing against everything
so what urine is not considered
traditional like Wilkens convenience so
it actually I mean in Canada it is
because our we have a we have a network
the CBC yeah yeah so we you know we
premiere January 8th for season 3 on
Canadian TV on traditional network but
then we have kind of like a second run
where after we finish our run on TV
we'll go on Netflix that's cool for
international release right we found it
really like even in Canada like you know
there's a difference between having to
go to a streaming a native streaming
like a proprietary streaming app versus
like Netflix it's it's tough to Netflix
is just more accessible it's a huge
reach and everybody knows Netflix yeah
Netflix and chill baby yeah that's true
that's the thing cool man
that's dope
[Music]